when bravely second end layer comes to
North America and the rest of the world
outside of Japan it will come with
changes based on overwhelming feedback
from players I'm Lucy and welcome to
your slightly different gamespot news
update these changes are meant to
improve the quality of the game and
don't affect the gameplay or story
Nintendo's released an official
statement explaining why one particular
side quest will be changed the pulse
statement reads based on feedback
received after bravely second and layers
release in Japan the development team at
Square Enix in conjunction with silicon
studio decided to implement a number of
revisions to the game for the purpose of
improving its quality and creating a
more enjoyable product one such change
affects the game's optional side quests
where players encounter a conflict
between two opposing parties and choose
search party to side with when the game
was released in Japan each side quest
would end with the team lamenting the
decision they made regardless of the
players decision this was intended to
help players empathize with the
characters situation but overwhelming
feedback from players indicated that
they felt an unsatisfying disconnect
between their intentions and the
characters reactions in response the
side quest endings were amended to show
the party readily coming to terms with
their actions in a manner that does not
cause the player undo regret for their
decisions these changes do not affect
the gameplay all the course of events in
the game and were made with the
intention of improving the game
experience for players this isn't the
first time Nintendo has made changes to
a Western release Fire Emblem fates had
several features unseen s removed
including a feature that allows players
to touch the screen to pet characters
and a controversial scene that featured
an expression which may be considered as
gay conversation or drugging Nintendo
later released a statement to explain
why the scene change was necessary so
what do you think about the slight
change let me know in the comments below
or come find me on Twitter I Malusi
James games for more on bravely second
keep it gamespot
you